a lot of you have asked me to do one on
this a video on the 7th Day Adventist
Church where' they come from what do
they believe and are they biblical watch
to the end because I'm going to give you
10 ways in which the 7th Day Adventist
Church or SDA for short differs from
standard Christian beliefs looking at
their official sources some of these
actually shocked me quite a bit but
firstly how did they start in the early
1800s there was in North America a lot
of expectation about Christ's return his
second coming or Advent hence the name
Adventist a man named William Miller
predicted that Jesus would return on
October 22nd 1844 based on his
interpretation of Daniel 8:14 and a
timeline he had created from that but
that day in 1844 came and went just like
every other day Christ did not return
and so his failed prediction led to what
people called the great disappointment
Jesus didn't come back on that day
Miller admitted his error that he
shouldn't be predicting dates of
Christ's return as Jesus himself said no
one knows the day or the hour and Jesus
will come back like a thief in the night
but in the morning following the great
disappointment of October 22nd 1844 a
man named heram Edson claimed to have
seen a vision he saw Jesus standing at
the altar of heaven and concluded that
William Miller was right about the date
but wrong about the location in other
words he thought Christ's return was not
back to this Earth but into a Heavenly
Sanctuary a different part of heaven and
this soon sparked the Seventh Day
Adventist movement of which James and
Ellen G white were the driving force
Ellen White was someone who claimed to
have some 2,000 Visions from God all
kinds of new revelation ranging from
what food you allowed to eat to the mark
of the beast being Sunday Worship in the
future now here are the 10 beliefs of
this SDA church that differs from
standard Christian teaching stay with me
to the end some of these get quite
interesting number one LG white even
though the Adventist Church claims that
the Bible is the Supreme revelation of
God's will they hold to Ellen White as
the messenger of the Lord a title she
claimed for herself and is still used
today in the official Church manual at
the 2015 General Conference session the
SDA Church stated we reaffirm our
conviction that her writings are
divinely in inspired whoo divinely
inspired that's the very thing they say
about the Bible that is given by divine
inspiration yet they claim Ellen's
writings are as well friends no one's
writings are divinely inspired besides
the authors of scripture now the
Adventist Church will claim that her
writings are not as authoritative as the
Bible itself but if you read through the
SDA official Church manual she is quoted
just as often as the Bible itself if not
more so number two the Sabbath
Adventists go to church on Saturday not
Sunday now there's nothing wrong with
that in of itself as Paul says in Romans
14 but the problem is the SDA Church
thinks that the Sabbath is binding on a
Christian today because it's found in
the Ten Commandments in the law of Moses
but the New Testament makes clear that
Christ fulfilled the law and that as
Christians we're not under the law we're
under the law of Christ and the
instructions on how we are to live are
found in the New Testament Plus in the
Old Testament the Sabbath law was only
for the Jewish people anyway not for the
rest of the Nations and the Sabbath
wasn't about what day you had to go to
church on but the day the Jews had to
rest from work Ellen White considered
that going to church on Saturday would
be the Seal of God while Sunday worship
would be the mark of the beast not what
the Bible says number three Soul sleep
the Adventist Church teach that you
don't have an immortal Soul so if you
die you're asleep until Judgment Day now
the Bible does speak about people's
bodies sleeping but never about
someone's Soul sleeping the Bible even
speaks in Revelation 6 about these
people who were killed for their faith
in Jesus and they're already in heaven
and they're asking God oh Sovereign Lord
holy and true how long before you will
judge and avenge our blood on those who
dwell on the earth they're not asleep if
they're speaking there is no soul Sleep
Number Four annihilationism 7eventh Day
Adventists believe that hell is not
Eternal conscious torment as the Bible
says but but instead they think that
unbelievers will simply be annihilated
they'll cease to exist eventually but
that really downplays hell it makes hell
not too bad then going extinct in hell
is exactly what an unbeliever would want
anyway it's what atheists were expecting
right but it's not what is going to
happen because it doesn't fit with the
biblical texts such as Revelation 14
which speaks about people having no rest
day or night and the smoke of their
torment ascending forever and ever the
smoke of that torment can Ascend forever
and ever because they must be being
tormented forever and ever number five
investigative judgment the SDA Church
teach that Jesus entered into the
sanctuary in heaven on October 22nd 1844
to begin investigative judgment upon
those who've been forgiven to see if
they are worthy of eternal life namely
are they keeping God's Commandments but
the Bible never speaks of any such thing
it never speaks about Jesus entering
into a different place in heaven on
October 22nd 1844 since Christ descended
he's already been and the holy of holies
in heaven interceding for us plus if God
is determining who is worthy of eternal
life based on keeping Commandments
that's opposite to the gospel we are
saved by grace through faith not by
keeping the Commandments number six
Satan Bears our sins from the Adventist
website quote in the final cleansing of
Sin from the universe there will be a
final scapegoat Satan the arch deceiver
who will bear the sins of the righteous
when the sanctuary in heaven is cleansed
those sins will be transferred to Satan
whoa this is bad the Bible says Jesus
bore our sins in his body on the tree
Jesus alone not Satan Satan will bear
his own sins not anyone else's if Satan
Bears our sins that in some sense makes
Satan the Savior rather than Jesus
Christ that's bad number seven man-made
rules like other churches who believe in
Revelation outside the Bible the
Adventist too have a set of man-made
rules stemming from Ellen White let me
give you three examples in order to be a
member of the SDA Church a person must
abstain from alcohol now the Bible says
getting drunk is sinful but it never
says You must abstain from alcohol
altogether in fact Jesus and the
disciples drank one that would mean
Jesus and the disciples could not be
members of the SDA church that's a
problem if you exclude Jesus from your
church because of your own man-made
rules they also say certain genres of
music are out of bounds here's a quote
from the official Church manual any
Melody partaking of the nature of jazz
rock or related hybrid forms will be
shunned dancing is also forbidden Ellen
White said and this is quoted in the
church manual the amusement of dancing
is a school of depravity a fearful curse
to society none of these things are
forbidden in the Bible that is man-made
rules number eight The Remnant Church
the 7th Day Adventist Church claims that
they are the remnant church for the last
days due to to widespread apostasy they
think they are the remnant Church
ultimately because they keep the Sabbath
but the Bible never speaks of a Remnant
church it's always a worrying sign
whenever any church or organization
claims to have a special status upon
itself as the special Church of today's
day and age to be baptized in the SDA
Church a person must agree that the SDA
church is the remnant Church number nine
baptismal vows generally when a person
gets baptized in a regular a Christian
Church the person will simply need to
affirm that they have faith in Jesus
Christ but in the SDA Church according
to the official Church manual a person
must make a set of vows agreeing to all
the distinctives of the SDA Church the
28 fundamental beliefs they need to also
vow to keep the SDA diet of food and
drink vow to keep the Sabbath and vow to
pay a tithe that is 10% of their income
to the SDA church that sounds like an
initiation not a baptism biblically
speaking baptism is simply a declaration
of a person's faith in Jesus Christ not
faith in a particular denomination
number 10 Health rules Ellen White
claimed that the gospel being proclaimed
in the last days would contain a message
about health she was a vegetarian and so
most 7eventh day Adventists are as well
eating meat is discouraged in adventism
but not forbidden but what is forbidden
is any unclean food from The Book of
Leviticus such as pork or shellfish but
the New Testament makes clear that we're
not under the Mosaic law was all food is
clean Jesus said and Paul said in Romans
that nothing is indeed unclean anymore
even God said to Noah After the flood
regarding the animals every moving thing
that lives shall be food for you and as
I gave you the green plants I give you
everything Genesis 9:3 that must include
pork and shellfish they can now be on
the menu while I have no doubt there are
saved people within the SDA church but
because of these 10 reasons I would not
recommend the seventh day Adventist
Church to someone I think the way
forward for them is to let go of Ellen
White's teachings and admit she was
wrong on these points and hold the Bible
as the only Revelation to rely upon can
I encourage you all show your Adventist
friends love and kindness pray for them
and help them see what the Bible says on
these important issues